cnn is spatting off on science again and
they seem pretty confused cnn reporting
yesterday
that there is no consensus on how to
assign sex at birth they write quote
christie gnomes
executive orders reference biological
sex
a disputed term that refers to the sex
as listed
on students original birth certificates
it's not possible to know a person's
gender identity at birth
and there is no consensus criteria for
assigning
sex at birth now listen i'm no doctor
you know i didn't go to medical school
i'm no biologist
i think that with 100
certainty i will always be able to
know whether a little boy is a little
boy or whether he's a little girl
more broadly if we cannot know
if we can not know for sure the
difference between little boys and
little girls
there is no hope for self-government not
surprised
cnn is confused i'm michael knowles the
michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday comes from alex z
who says knowles's transitions of
promoting his book
are as seamless as the pre-order process
for speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now on
amazon that's true also by the way
that's a great thank you so much for
that transition
alex uh the uh some people have written
in and they've
they've wanted to know if they can get
an autographed copy and i don't really
know because i'm not
particularly involved in the process
of putting this out in different stores
and all that but i googled it yesterday
after i got some emails
and it turns out you can pre-order an
autographed first edition
of the book uh you can do that at
premier collectibles so if you're
interested head on over there
it's just it's so much easier than you
know having to wait in a long line to do
something
same thing could be true of auto parts
if you want to get auto parts and you
don't want to wait in line and you don't
want to pay
twice as much you need to go to
rockauto.com great family business great
supporters of the show
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store and someone
demanding quick answers to things like
hey
is your odyssey an lx or an ex i don't
know
i don't know what kind of x my odyssey
is then you know you go out they'll i'll
go back and say okay it's this kind of x
and they'll say okay they go in the back
they don't have the part they go online
they look up the part they order it
probably from rockauto.com they come out
they charge you twice as much don't do
that
that's humiliating you can go to
rockauto.com right from your
desk right from your cell phone you head
on over there it's family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
the catalog is so easy to navigate
somehow even
i can do it they're not gimmicky with
their prices it's not like a tuesday you
know it's
50 more and then wednesday no they just
always reliably low same prices for pros
and do-it-yourselfers head on over to
rockauto.com
right now check out all the parts
available for your car
or truck then write knowles k-w-l-e-s
in there how did you hear about his box
so they know we sent you
you need to be able to know things
if you are going to govern yourselves
so you need to be able i'm not saying
you need to have
100 perfect certainty for all times
everywhere
of the exact nature of justice in the
regime
of the exact meaning of liberty and
equality but you need to kind of know
what these things are
and you need to be part of the broader
conversation that we have in our country
and in our civilization you need to be
able to use your faculties of reason
and your moral conscience to separate
good from bad and right from wrong and
true from false and if you can't do that
you can't rule yourself while
cnn is pretending that we can't know
whether to put the blue hat or the pink
hat on the newborn baby
while the elites are pretending not to
know
the most obvious things on earth you'll
notice that
gender reveal parties are
gaining steam it seems like every week
now we're hearing about
gender reveal parties this was not
really a thing
when i was little this is this is
clearly becoming more of a cultural norm
that i actually was tempted to do it
myself for uh for a sweet little
junior when when he was going to come
out sweet little lisa thought that this
was just too
ridiculous and that as a self-respecting
man i should not be as excited
to do this but the idea is you you go
and the doctor figures out the sex of
the baby which they can now do very
early on
and then they write it down on a sheet
of paper and then i don't know maybe you
bring that to a baker and you say you
know if it's a boy
then make bake me of cake with blue
frosting on the inside
if it's a girl bake me a cake with pink
frosting on the inside
and now these rituals have become much
more elaborate
there have been stories about people
setting off fireworks there was
and getting harmed in the way by the way
people have died during these gender
reveal parties so there was actually a
very sad story in mexico
a couple hired some people to fly a
plane with the gender reveal
on the back of it and then very
tragically
the plane crashed i think two people
died in this
incident which is uh you know awful i
mean accidents happen
but it is strange that we keep hearing
about all of these accidents for gender
reveal parties
does this mean that no one should ever
have a a gender reveal sort of party
ever again
uh no i don't i don't think so uh
sad things happen the plural of anecdote
is not data
however it does speak to a problem that
we we have as a society
which is we're making too big a deal
out of ordinary things
you see this most especially with
weddings
as the weddings get more and more and
more elaborate it seems like
marriage rates and are declining and
divorce rates are skyrocketing and
marriage itself means less of what it
once did
as proposals wedding proposals become
more and more and more elaborate
the institution of marriage becomes much
more confused
as the gender reveal parties become more
and more and more elaborate our
grasp on what sex even is becomes more
confused
i think we're over rationalizing things
here
i think everything's such a big deal
that we
i know people who won't get married
because they don't have
50 000 saved up to have a big fancy
elaborate wedding that is a new
phenomenon people used to just get
married even rich people had smaller
affairs
than we do now there are people who
want to take everything that we used to
just do as a
matter of course in society and agonize
over it and
you know try to figure out is little
johnny really little johnny or
do i need to watch if he ever reaches
for a barbie is he little jane
i i think that this is very likely a
just the consequence of this critical
process we've had in society this is
actually something you hear a lot about
in the academy
critical race theory or critical theory
more broadly or the ruthless criticism
of all that exists which coincidentally
i mentioned quite a lot and and
described in detail in my book
speechless this has been an
organized effort to analyze and
criticize
every single aspect of society to
deconstruct it
the end point of that is we can't do
anything natural anymore we can't just
go get married
let's do it let's fall in love now it's
well we need to have a relationship
and it's got to be very clinical and
it's and maybe we're going to
have a a new kind of strange
relationship and maybe we're going to
have a throuple like you see on those
weird tv shows
and maybe we're going to if we get
married it's we have to delay the
wedding by two years of an engagement
and then we
you know it's we're so clumsy about
everything we do in society right now
why can't we just
act normally for lack of a better word
why
is everything so in question national
borders are now in question
that whether or not a country is allowed
to have borders that's now somehow a
disputed
matter whether you salute the american
flag and stand for the national anthem
that is now a disputed matter
whether you should have ballot integrity
that is now a disputed matter
heavily dis we can't do any of the basic
things that you need to do
to get to the higher questions of
society i'll give you another example of
this
juan williams on on fox news i actually
really like juan williams
he's always been very nice to me and i
find a lot of his commentary
at least thought provoking but he gave a
pretty weak answer the other day he was
he was asked about that awful carjacking
of those two
young girls who there was two young
black girls who carjack a pakistani guy
and then kill him and then callously
they just don't care at all they walk
past they walk back to the crime scene
past his dead body
because one of the girls forgot her cell
phone in the car
and this topic was brought up in a
discussion and juan williams
tried to find every elaborate answer
except for the obvious one
i think in part what it is is you got
it's tragic i mean you got these
teenage girls i mean they're little kids
not they're not
gangsters they're not hardened criminals
i don't think they intended to kill
anybody they were looking for have a
joyride
and it just went way wrong way out of
control and ended up in a
gross tragedy i mean this is
unbelievable their lives are ruined well
they brought a stun gun
and so usually you don't bring a stun
gun into a joy ride but go
i just think correct i mean it's like
you know kids finding guns in their
parents
i don't know what to say jesse it's
awful it's a terrible situation
so the question is why would these girls
do it and juan's answer is
you know that maybe maybe they weren't
trying to
carjack the guy and maybe they actually
weren't just callously disregarding his
life maybe they
wanted to go for a joyride and then
jesse waters says well you know they
brought a
stun gun with them yeah well maybe they
yeah and maybe their parents just left
that around and maybe
they maybe was all a big accident maybe
it's all a big misunderstanding maybe
they're really good kids
maybe the simplest answer is the correct
one maybe they're just
bad kids and we all have fallen broken
nature
and some people turn out worse than
others and maybe they
they're they just did a very evil thing
because they had evil motivations and
they don't care about human life and
they at the very least need to be locked
up forever
there there's this concept of occam's
razor which
without being too elaborate about it is
this idea that all things being equal
the simplest explanation for a
phenomenon should be preferred to
unnecessarily complex answers for it
what happened to that in our culture why
can't we get back to occam's culture
why is it that if i look at a little boy
and he looks like a little boy
and he he has all the body parts of a
little boy and his dna is that of a
little boy
why do i have to be confused about that
and say well we don't know
why why can't we just accept what is
obviously true before our eyes if our
country
that we are now told is the worst
country in the world and it's the source
of evil in the world and we need to
destroy our country and open up the
borders and we owe everything to
everybody
why is it that everyone from the rest of
the world wants to come here why is it
that
we why is it that we have to have such a
robust security system in our on our
border
why is it that millions of people come
here every single year is it possible
that the simplest solution is the
correct one is it possible that we're
just a good country
and an attractive place to live and and
have your life and raise your family
is that possible no somehow we are
preferring the the most ridiculous rube
goldberg
complex answers to the common sense
that and the obvious solutions that we
can see before
our very eyes mark hamill's
showing this recently luke skywalker
he's saying that
he's advancing this narrative that
america is a terrible country
tweets out no more filming in georgia no
more filming in the state of georgia not
the country of georgia
because georgia passed an election
integrity law
after they upended so many of their
election measures
in the 2020 election says no more
filming hollywood boycotting georgia
why why is hollywood boycotting georgia
well because they might have some
voter id maybe they might make people
vote you know in person
more often than they vote by mail they
might not let you buy votes at the
polling place
mark hamill filmed the first star wars
in tunisia
okay tunisia's got got some problems
hollywood films in a lot of places that
have a lot of
problems but they never worry about
anyone else's problems they only
focus in on the sins
and even the false sins the totally
contrived fabricated sins
of america what if
instead of cr and then they'll say well
hold on guys how are you saying america
is worse than
some of these other places in the world
they'll say well because actually
secretly
america in her inner most sin
is ian so she looks really good but
she's really evil
yeah that we heard this example the
other day if a racial minority attacks
another racial minority actually
secretly that's white supremacy how
about you just
how about we just go for the simplest
answer is that so hard i hope that's not
so hard
hollywood is not the only group doing
this
delta airlines i guess the most
woke airline as far as i can tell
coca-cola
too are joining the bandwagon of people
criticizing georgia for trying to
protect the election
they are sending out these mass
missives saying you know yes this this
is terrible we
oppose this what do i care what the ceo
of delta things
well because we have a hub in delta okay
well
i'm all for free markets as you know
if you are using your corporate power
to undermine the basic protections
of our constitutional republic i'm
against you
i don't support that you shouldn't be
allowed to do that
i don't know what political power the
republicans in georgia
have right now over these companies but
they should exercise it if that's
removing certain tax breaks
if that is removing certain privileges
that these companies have
they should exercise that we should not
permit
corporations to run roughshod over our
culture and upend our constitutional
norms any more
than we would want the government to do
that very
bad stuff what if instead of the
woke delta coca-cola
hollywood explanation of this georgia
law
that just brings back some very basic
voter integrity measures
what if that's not about white supremacy
and racism and suppressing the vote
and what if it's just because people
want fair elections
is that possible when voter id is put up
to public opinion surveys
everyone wants it every demographic
group
votes for voter id
it's white supremacy well black people
support voter id and that weird
it's going to suppress immigrants
hispanic people
support voter right everyone does
because it makes sense it's so obvious
the the people who oppose voter id are
the people who want to steal elections
it's that simple it's really not
complicated
the washington post as left-wing an
outlet as the washington post
admits that the narrative on the georgia
law the narrative that joe biden is
pushing
is bs joe biden says that the new law in
georgia
is going to shrink the opportunities
of people to vote here is what the
washington post fact checker says
on election day in georgia polling
places are open from 7 a.m to 7 p.m and
if you are in line by 7 pm
you are allowed to cast your ballot
nothing in the new law
changes those rules however the law did
make some changes to early voting
but experts say the net effect was to
expand
the opportunities to vote for most
georgians not limit them
so even the freaking washington post
as left-wing a mainstream outlet as it
gets
is admitting that joe biden and the
democrats narrative and coca-cola's
narrative and delta's narrative
on the georgia voting law is not only
false
it's perfectly false it's the opposite
it's the exact opposite
of true of what's really going on
now i've got to give credit where credit
is due
the washington post was being fair
there doesn't always happen sometimes
though there's
i guess a little pang of the old
institution
in these places and and more than that i
think they realize that some of the
narratives that the left is pushing are
just
just so beyond the pale that they're not
going to be politically very effective
so the washington post is being fair a
prominent journalist however
is in hot water right now for saying
that
fairness is overrated lester holt of nbc
news was winning
some award and he zoomed in to accept
the award
and he gave his sort of theory of
journalism
and one of the lines that he's really
catching a lot of flack for is
that fairness is overrated i think it's
become clear
that fairness is overrated well before
you run off and tweet that headline
let me explain a bit the idea that we
should always give
two sides equal weight and merit does
not reflect the world we find ourselves
in
that the sun sets in the west is a fact
and a contrary view does not deserve our
time or attention
i know recent events assure that you
won't have to look far to find more
current and relevant examples i think
you get my point
decisions to not give unsupported
arguments equal time
are not a dereliction of journalistic
responsibility or some kind of
agenda in fact it's just the opposite
providing an open platform for
misinformation for anyone to come say
whatever they want especially when
issues of public health and safety are
at stake can be quite dangerous
our duty is to be fair to the truth
holding those in power accountable is at
the core of our function
and responsibility lester holt
is absolutely right on the point about
fairness what he's implying i think and
if you listen to the rest of his speech
you'll see
he's implying that basically the
conservatives are the bad guys and the
liberals are the good guys at least in
recent history
so he goes off on donald trump and he's
saying yeah we shouldn't be totally fair
by giving trump supporters or president
trump himself
equal airtime or anything like that so
obviously i disagree with that point
but on the procedural point that
fairness is overrated
whatever we even mean by fairness today
that the idea that you should
hear both sides of any question equally
lester holt
is absolutely right and the left
understands this
and the right used to understand this
and the left tricked the right into not
understanding this
which is why we are in our present
confusion this is why for instance
conservatives now embrace free speech
absolutism
whatever that means free speech
absolutism is very different than the
actual american free speech tradition
of our founding fathers and all the men
who built this country and the men who
before our founding fathers and the
broader the broader
anglo tradition free
free speech has always had some limits
on it we've mentioned it on this show
many times
sedition threats fraud fighting words
obscenity there have always been limits
on these things
free speech absolutism says there can be
no limits whatsoever but that's not
practical it's not possible because we
we need to get along together in society
words have to mean certain things right
words cannot just mean whatever we want
them to mean and if words mean certain
things
then words actually can infringe on
people's rights fraud is a clear example
of this
if you use your speech to commit fraud
you are committing a crime that speech
cannot be permitted
if you are using your speech for
obscenity
most people myself included who have
considered this question before
especially on the conservative side
realize that obscenity is not protected
speech because it actually undermines
speech
because it is simply prurient it tries
to arouse base passions it actually
undermines
our higher faculties of reason it
undermines our liberty and so liberty
and license is not the same thing
we could go on for hours about what the
founding fathers had to say about that
the right in america used to
acknowledge that there is objective
truth and that we can know certain
truths
we uh william f buckley jr put it in
this very silly phrase he said that he
was an epistemological optimist
certain things are settled and we ought
to acknowledge them as settled
no one thinks that there should be some
kind of
constitutional right to scream zig heil
at the water cooler at the office and
have you keep your job
no one really believes that we we on the
right now adopt the language of
believing that because we pretend to be
free speech absolutists who believe that
everything ought to be in the free
marketplace of ideas but of course
marketplaces have rules that are set by
the broader political
regime and the broader political
tradition
we should not tolerate in the academy
in the classroom or in many other places
in our public sphere
the idea that men are really women and
therefore we should pump kids full of
hormones and chop off their appendages
that is not an idea that we should
tolerate it's just not true it's
patently false there's no argument for
it
the only way you can make an argument
for it is by making an argument to
undermine reason
in the classroom specifically we we have
this question of
critical race theory should this sort of
thing be taught in
public schools let's say no it should
not
because it's not merely some radical
idea that perhaps will broaden our
perspective
it is it is as chesterton said the
thought that stops thought
it is an idea that undermines our
our acknowledgement of reason it is an
idea
that undermines the purpose of education
you have to get rid of that
and no notion of fairness should should
impel us
to give equal weight to those things
when when the left speaks i think very
often the right just wants to dismiss it
but i think we should take a lesson from
them this is the thing that i try to do
in my book speechless available now for
pre-order you know
this show that we're on right now at the
daily wire this show is available
uh to everybody it's available on
youtube it's available
on facebook it's available all over the
place at least for a lot of the show
but we have a new show at the daily wire
that is
not available to everybody all the time
that show
of course is candace candace candace
owens is a new show is available
exclusively to daily wire members so if
you are not a member yet go to
dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace to get 25
off that is code candace c-a-n-d-a-c-e
for 25 off join now so you can tune in
friday night
for a closer look behind her hot takes
head on over to dailywire.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
some unfortunate news for holy week
church membership in the united states
is below 50
for the first time ever
this according to new gallup poll
americans membership and houses of
worship continued to decline last year
dropping below 50 percent for the first
time in gallup's
eight decade trend in 2020 47
of americans said they belonged to a
church synagogue or mosque
down from 50 in 2018 and
70 in 1999. so the way this is being
reported
is that this is a massive decline in the
religiosity of americans
but i don't think that's true i think
it's just
a change in the religiosity of americans
i think
that in 1999 70 of americans
were christian and and there was much
smaller number were
muslim or jewish and i think now
47 percent are christian muslim or
jewish
and 53 are something else
because to quote bob dylan everybody's
got to serve somebody
everybody has religious views everybody
the most hardened atheist
has religious views because man is a
religious being because all human
conflict
at the end of the day is theological and
because we have natural religious
longings in our core
so some people are christians
they believe that god sent his only
begotten son to die
for mankind and redeem us to die for our
sins
to be crucified and buried on good
friday
and to rise again from the dead on
easter sunday
and then to ascend to heaven and sit at
the right hand of god the father
almighty and
that he will one day come again to judge
living the dead that is a creed
for christians if you are let's say
you're
an atheist right now but you're a woke
atheist
then you believe that little boys can be
little girls that is that is a religious
view what you are saying is that the the
soul
we have souls first of all that our
souls are totally different from our
bodies
and when there is disagreement between
our soul and our body that the soul wins
out that we are
physical that we are metaphysical beings
essentially and that our the physical
world
has nothing to do with it and frankly
can be evil because it
uh contradicts our metaphysical truth
okay
if you are i don't know one of these
people who says i'm spiritual but not
religious
you are religious you're just
narcissistic as well
i hate to be harsh about it but i once
heard a comedian describe spiritual but
not religious
is the same thing as saying i i i don't
really care that much about god but i'm
very interested in myself
what does it mean to be spiritual but
not religious or to say you know i
i'm very interested in this spirituality
but i'm not interested in organized
religion what it means is
you have i'll give a more charitable
read of it it means you have natural
religious longings and you acknowledge
them and you recognize that obviously
there is something beyond this physical
world because the world doesn't make any
sense if there isn't
but you just don't care to
think systematically about it and you
don't want
the transcendent moral order to make any
demands of you
and you don't want to have to to
acquiesce to those demands
and i say this as someone who for a
period of time might have called himself
spiritual but not religious so i get it
you know i understand why that's
compelling and why it's why it's very
fashionable today
but that is a sort of religion whether
whether one wants to admit it or not
the most hardened materialist let's say
an outright communist
in the streets who says you know there
is no god
religion is the opium of the people and
we need to build the progressive society
here on earth
because of the science of history i know
that the arc of history
is long but it bends toward justice and
we are go progress is in the way and
you're on the wrong side of history that
is a religious view
that is a sort of eschatological view
it's a view that that
sees the end times but the the end time
that those sorts of people would see
is is a happy one right well one where
we build this wonderful society and the
state falls away and we're all living
in this utopia that is a religious view
as well
you can't evade it
and people who convince themselves that
they're not religious i think often fall
into these problems
much better i think to acknowledge yes
you are necessarily going to have
religious views
because our our very faculties of reason
rest on certain religious foundations
and then you have to start thinking
about those views well what does that
mean does that mean that i acknowledge
that god exists well if
god exists what does that mean does that
mean i have to grapple with the person
of christ
does that mean what does that mean for
other religions what does that mean for
my behavior today what does that mean
for how i should live my life
i would uh i urge the 53 of americans
who are confused on this issue
don't be duped don't be distracted don't
be fooled by people who are
who are trying to take your attention
away from
serious and eternal things one
sort of joke of this whole survey is you
know gosh can you believe that people
left church in such high numbers in 2020
yeah i can because the powers that be
wouldn't let us go to church for a very
long period of time
remember when the public health
officials who are actually the priests
of our
secular religion and who perform the
liturgy of liberalism
remember when they said hey marijuana
shops those are essential services
but going to church absolutely not no
way yeah no surprise
and for those who who respond to this
and say well michael look come on
politicians can never change the culture
because politics is downstream of
culture
look at east germany east germany was
run by the communists during the cold
war west germany was run
by the west right in west germany you
had religion east germany you had state
imposed communism
now here we are three decades after the
fall of the berlin wall
west germany continues to have a high
degree of religious identification
christian identification east germany
continues
to be an atheist place the people
identify as atheists
there you might say culture was
downstream from politics or really
what you're seeing is just that politics
and culture
are not so easily separated and
there there is a political regime in in
the west broadly but
specifically in this country right now
that is very hostile to religion
there is a president right now who sues
nuns
because they won't pay for abortion
drugs and
contraception and so it's no surprise
that that's having an effect
we we didn't cover it on this show but
there was this awful suicide bombing
outside a cathedral on palm sunday in
indonesia palm sunday is the longest
liturgy of the year
so you had a lot of people who hillary
clinton might call easter worshipers
also known as christians who went to
this cathedral and there was a suicide
bombing
i don't think anyone's claimed
responsibility muslim militants have
committed these sorts of actions before
in that part of the world so it might be
that might be what's going on
unfortunately i don't think very many
people were killed
a lot of people were injured i mentioned
it um because
it's a reminder that as we are in holy
week as we approach good friday tomorrow
and easter sunday after that as we
think back on our heritage as a
christian nation no matter what the
libs want to tell you this is a
christian nation it's a nation
that is founded essentially on christian
principles and christian ideas and even
the practice
of christianity in in varying ways
christianity is the most persecuted
religion on earth
christians are the most persecuted
religious group on earth there was a
survey to this effect that came out from
pew research
a few years ago this is contradicted by
the
left-wing narrative where we're told
that christianity
is actually we're they're the
persecutors those christians
and there's such a thing as christian
nationalism that's rising up and we need
to tamp it
tamp it down and christians should not
be able to follow their conscience and
we should have
the federal government suing nuns and
that sort of thing
christianity christianity is the
persecuted religion
there is no question about that and
you're seeing this
uh more and more clearly as christianity
becomes a minority
religion in america you're going to see
these attacks on the church
become much clearer if you think it's
bad now with
egghead public health officials shutting
down churches
arbitrarily and with the president of
the united states supporting
lawsuits against nuns just wait
and see what happens if that number
continues to shrink as
sadly i'm afraid it probably will there
is a new religion of wokeness of leftism
call whatever you want
it comes with a rigid racial caste
system you see this in marin county
california in marin county right now
the supervisors their plan to contribute
funds to a
universal basic income program that will
give just a blank check to people to
test out and see how you
ubi works this was something that was
pushed in the democratic primaries in
2020 by andrew yang
however this ubi system is not going to
be you
the universal part of universal basic
income is going to be taken out
this program is going to be restricted
to people on the basis of race and sex
only non-white women are eligible
so tax dollars are going to be put into
a fund and then these supervisors are
going to distribute those tax dollars
only to non-white women and they're
going to call it
universal basic income because they
think that the only
people who are entitled to these sorts
of things
universally speaking are the specific
group
of women uh they'll spend three million
bucks to provide a thousand dollars to
125 low-income women each month
specifically on the basis of their race
the women must also have a child who's
under 18 years old
and now they're getting some pushback
for that and they say no we just want
the money to go
where it's most needed and black women
statistically are poorer than white
women and so we're going to give it to
the black women
if the point of the plan is to give it
the money where it is
most needed financially why don't you
just give it to the poor women
well no because black women are poorer
than white women right but there are
some black women who are
who are wealthier than some white women
so if the whole point is a financial one
then just give it to the white women
but that's or just give it to the poor
white women
and the poor black women and the poor
hispanic women and whoever else in the
basis of finances this shows you
this conflict that's that we have right
now which is right now
most racial discrimination is prohibited
by law there is
one carve out which is affirmative
action the idea that
black and hispanic applicants to college
and jobs
get legal privileges and that white and
asian applicants to college and jobs
have a legally protected disadvantage on
the basis of their race and that's just
just a weird carve out in our law but
generally speaking we do not
permit racial discrimination in our law
increasingly leftist politicians want to
enact
racial discrimination against whites and
asians and for
black people and hispanic people and
you're seeing
most clearly in laws like this but there
are other sorts of laws being proposed
but they're not able to do that yet
because the law remains what it is so
they're trying to pretend that it no
it's really about economics it's really
about finances it's really
socio this no it's not they're just
trying to impose
a racial caste system and that is very
very bad
speaking of race hustling politicians
kamala harris
has now been put in charge of the border
crisis president joe biden has said he's
putting his
vice president in charge of it and yet
kamala harris was asked about this and
she said
she has no plans to visit the border
right now
what's going on what's going on
is a stroke of political brilliance from
joe biden
it's politically brilliant but it's
often done
which is when a president is faced with
a really really tough
issue that has no political upside for
them
whatever happens they give the issue to
the vice president
so this is actually it's not just a
party line thing donald trump did this
to mike pence
when the coronavirus hit and when the
public health regime
and many democrats had basically put
donald trump in this
corner where he anything he did it was
if he embraced
the masks and the lockdowns and you know
really did a good job
and kept those infection and death
numbers down
then he would be accused by his own
people of upending the constitution and
overreacting and falling for the
for the trap sort of the criticism that
i made at the time
but if he ignored the the advice of the
experts
any death from the virus would be put at
his feet
and so he would he would also have
difficulty in reelection
anything he did was a problem so what
did he do he said mike pence
you are leading the coronavirus task
force it's the same thing here with
with immigration anything biden does is
a loss for him
if he enforces the law and actually
ships these
foreign nationals back to their
countries his own base will turn
on him the the broader public
supports enforcing our immigration laws
but the democratic base
opposes enforcing our immigration laws
so that looks bad for him
yet if joe biden says okay surge come to
the border
sort of some things he said during the
primaries to win over democratic
base voters if he starts saying that
borders wide open come on through
he's going to lose support among the
majority of americans according to
public opinion surveys so there's just
nothing he can do here
so kamala harris gets it kamala you're
now in charge of the border okay
kamala harris is a crafty politician too
she knows that if she goes to the border
and she's identified
in photographs and filmed with this with
this crisis
her political career is going to take a
big hit so she's saying yes i'm dealing
with it diplomatically
here from the white house and don't
worry
i'm in charge but don't hold me too
responsible for it
it's a a classic political maneuver
and they're they're both playing it
pretty well right now but the crisis is
getting worse and worse and worse at a
certain point you think something's got
to give
speaking of clever politicians
remember andrew cuomo remember that guy
andrew cuomo
he was going to be impeached or he was
going to resign or he
but i told you weeks and weeks ago i
said do not count this guy out this is a
clever politician
he's a bulldog he's been in new york
state politics since he was in diapers
and this guy is going to hold on until
the very end everyone said he's done
he'll resign within days i said i don't
think he's going to resign within days
hard to see how he holds on i know it's
a really tough scandal but
cuomo is holding on and so what he's
doing right now is
not addressing the contrived sex scandal
that he like winked at his secretary or
something
he's not addressing the real scandal
which is that he sent sick people to
nursing homes needlessly
killing thousands of elderly new yorkers
then he knew about that and then he
covered it up because he didn't want a
federal investigation into him
not that he's he is talking about
marijuana and a bunch of big dopes
are falling for it cuomo is legalizing
pot in new york
recreational marijuana uh for people
over the age of 21.
he's setting up a licensing process for
the delivery of
uh pot to potheads and
he's allowing new yorkers to grow up to
three
mature and three immature plants for
personal use
i think all marijuana plants are
immature if you ask me
think about that uh the bill was passed
by both the the
democrat led senate and assembly and
cuomo is all for it cuomo says this is
a historic day in new york one that
rights the wrongs of the past
by putting an end to harsh prison
sentences embraces an industry
that will grow the empire state's
economy and prioritizes marginalized
communities
prioritizes marginalized communities so
those that have suffered the most will
be the first to reap the benefits
isn't this kind of offensive to say like
listen legalizing marijuana legalizing
drugs is
is really helpful to black people
because everyone knows black people love
drugs
black people just naturally biologically
according to andrew cuomo
have a predilection for doing drugs and
just
wasting their day puffing on the devil's
lettuce
and so as a matter of racial justice we
need to let people
waste their time waste their time
puffing on that
sin spinach pretty offensive stuff but
what a what a silly silly distraction
first of all i love
the idea that the marijuana industry is
somehow they're the good guys i just
spoke with my friend
maddie currants from national review
about this she's a great piece
cover story and the spectator out right
now which you should
we you should listen to or read rather
called big dope you should also listen
to the interview
where she points out these are these are
bad guys these are you know if you think
big tobacco is bad
big dope is just as bad it's bad for
your health
these guys are trying to downplay the
health risks of smoking pot
which has all the same health risks as
smoking cigarettes all the tar all the
fear
of diseases and by the way some other
diseases thrown onto it because it
messes with your head so why are we
rooting for these guys i mean i
understand there is some argument for
decriminalizing marijuana i'm not
convinced by that argument but i
understand there's some argument for it
but the argument is not that this is a
matter of right that everyone needs to
be able to smoke pot in the marijuana
industry they're the good guys give me a
break
he's doing it of course to distract from
his actual political scandals
speaking of things that only make sense
if you have been
puffing on the jamaican oregano demi
lovato who i don't really know who she
is i think she's a singer or an actress
she went on joe rogan's podcast to
describe sex and gender the only thing
that
that we're talking about these days
because the left has taken away
our higher faculties of reason we no
longer debate
important matters or rather eternal
matters or rather higher matters
we're just talking about our loins and
the longings of our loins so demi lovato
says
that she's fluid now she's really fluid
she's no longer
congealed i don't know she's no longer
solid she's fluid
and so she's actually a pansexual take a
listen
i'm so fluid now
and a part of the reason why i
am so fluid is because i was like super
closeted off you mean like sexually
fluid yeah yeah you like
girls you like boys yeah yeah yeah
um anything really so
i just what do they call that like
pansexual or something like that yeah
yeah pansexual it's hilarious fluid
you're fluid
what do you mean fluid well like like
you like girls or boys
oh i like anything really isn't that so
good
she's really open i don't mean to knock
on demi lovato she's representative of a
broader culture
it's it's good to be open it's bad to be
closed
it's good to just have your loins
titillated by anything
and it's bad to have preferences it's
bad to
say some things are good something's bad
something's right some things are wrong
so demi lovato is sexually attracted to
anything
so she's sexually attracted to kids
right
because kids are within the subset of
anything so
and she's fluid and she's open so she's
probably and she's attracted to animals
right
sexually because she's attracted to
anything she's a pansexual she's
attracted to any she's attracted to my
leftist years tumbler right
it's in the no i guess the leftist
year's tumblr much much less
objectionable than
the kids or the animals no i i bet if i
asked her this right now i said
you're attracted to kids and animals
she's like no oh my gosh no what are you
drawing you sicko what are you talking
about oh okay so then you're not
attracted you're not totally fluent some
things are solid
there are some guard reels here you're
not totally open
you're somewhat closed-minded as
you should be it is good to be somewhat
closed-minded
skepticism has utility only when it
leads to conviction to quote william f
buckley jr quoting a prominent liberal
in god and man at yale
some people are so open-minded that
their brains
fall out fluid
open we can't know anything we're just
we're everything man you know it's just
kind of whatever
man i got to get to new york don't i no
no i don't
i don't think so we we are in a moment
where our culture wants to deny
that we can say anything and and the
right has fallen for this worse than the
left has
at least the left continues to pursue
their own political agenda they at least
continue to exert their
their will if not their reason but we on
the right we've fallen for we said well
we can't
look if i say one thing's good then you
might say another thing is good and
that's just values and preferences man
and we can't know anything for sure and
we can't use our reason
no guys put down the bong
okay recognize that there is such a
thing
as truth goodness justice
beauty we can kind of know these things
and when we can kind of know these
things we can govern ourselves we used
to know that in america
but i don't know maybe we're all
suffering a cultural short-term memory
loss or something maybe we've had
a few too many rips i'm michael noel's
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show president biden has a
brilliant new plan that will heal the
economy
aoc has some incisive thoughts on the
border crisis and dr jill biden the
greatest doctor in american history
speak spanish beautifully april fools
that's today on the ben shapiro show
give it a listen